In our previous video, we discussed about
what a lens is and also its various
types.
It is bounded by two surfaces… one of them
is spherical and the other?
Yes it is spherical or plane!
These are the different TYPES of lenses!
The two specific lenses that we are going
to cover in this course are called
biconvex and biconcave lenses.
Each one is bounded by two transparent
SPHERICAL surfaces.
Hence the word BI is used… it means two!
In a biconvex
lens, the two spherical surfaces are curved
“inwards”, and in a biconcave lens,
they are curved “outwards”.
One more way to distinguish between a convex
and a concave lens is that a convex lens is
THICKER at the centre and THINNER
at the edges, while the concave lens is thicker
at the edges and thinner at the
centre.
Why do we use lenses?
What does a lens do?
In our previous video we saw a
few examples where lenses are used…
In binoculars and magnifying glasses for
instance...
But how does a lens function?
Well the main purpose of the lens is
to REFRACT the light in SOME PATTERN.
There are basically two patterns:
CONVERGENCE and DIVERGENCE.
But before studying these two patterns, we
first need to understand how the
light is refracted by a lens.
Consider a convex lens, and suppose a ray
of light is
incident onto it at an angle.
This is the normal at the point where the
light ray
is incident.
Now consider a point object here from where
this ray is emerging.
What will happen when it enters the lens?
This ray is travelling from one medium to
another at an angle, so after entering
the lens, its speed will change which will
result in its BENDING.
Will the speed
inside the lens increase or decrease?
Where will the light bend?
Well that will depend on the incident medium!
Suppose this medium is air.
So
from this table we can see that the refractive
index of glass is much greater
than air.
This means that glass is optically denser
Hence the speed of the ray of light will DECREASE
in glass and because of that,
it will bend TOWARDS the normal!
Alright!
So now what will happen when this refracted
ray has reached the
other spherical surface of the lens?
From there the ray will be refracted again
as it enters another medium which is
air again.
You see that this time, it bent AWAY from
the normal.
Can you tell
me why?
Air is optically denser than glass and hence
after entering air, speed of the ray
increases, and it bends AWAY from the normal.
And this is how the light ray is
refracted by a convex lens!
Here only one ray is emerging from the point
object.
But in reality there are
many rays that emerge from this point object
and not only one!
All these after striking the lens will be
refracted in the same way.
Did you see
something strange?
Yes, all the rays meet at a common point!
Or we can say that all the rays are
FOCUSSED or CONVERGED at a single point.
And this is one of the patterns that we were
talking about!
Convex lens bends the light rays from a point
object in such a way that after
refraction, all these rays converge at a single
point.
And this is the point where
the image of the point object is formed!
If we were to place a screen here at
this location, then the image will be formed
on that screen.
Since the convex lens CONVERGES all the light
rays at a single point, we also
call it a CONVERGING LENS.
And what about a concave lens?
How do they refract light rays?
We will see
that in the next lesson!